the second ago I'm giving a big lump of
iced tea and a half years back I just
joined was Lisa
so today I'll be talking about Ireland's
long-term dependencies and there are two
parts of this topic so in the first part
I will focus more of the long-term
repellency under the second fall and
focus more on the electron pair
enhancements so the first part is about
our new to play which is non saturating
our computers for modeling long-term
dependencies so if we think about how to
put the progress in people moved away
from saturating activation functions to
saturating our functions Bombeck and in
the case of recurrent networks because
children is that saturating activation
functions Domini especially because of
LSD n which is really this work aims to
introduce a non saturating recurrent
unit which the claim is better than
tennis teams in terms of problem
long-term difference so that's that's
the angle just to get started in it so
I'm sure tasks and maybe takes XTS input
and computes the pre activation which is
w times t minus 1 plus Q times HT w is a
recurrent wait and using usually you
have some longing energy on the top of
the speed deviation which is a toe
sigmoid
or time - so this is a very minimum iron
and we all know that like this mini iron
has problem of vanishing and exploring
the why is that okay because it's just
probably all the other clubs in the
equation on this consider this one of
them which is sketch now I can expand
this recurrence and write it as P is
equal to W over T times H 0 so now if we
are
and even decomposition of this power
lambda u transpose so but then this term
becomes a package deal with is basically
Q transpose lambda over T equals B okay
so now you have any backing that is a
less than one then you're multiplying
them by T times so the gradients are
going to vanish other than 1 when the
gradients will explode so this is one of
the classical problems in training
record neural networks simply because it
you have to choose your a current matrix
usually in such a way that thinking but
is lightweight close to water a little
bit more than one its gradient explore
ever is less than one periods are going
to ranch so that's the problem of
managing and exploiting gradients in in
an order so now let's just look at
vanishing gradient in the same Vanita
RNN if you want to compute and I can
write that as will be no itch last last
hidden state into Las Venus invite that
particular address so I can find to
expand this term it's basically a chain
rule of this excessive keep this one by
the verge scale right like so so now
let's look at what this different
changes if you differentiate this term
you're going to get if - any different
shades that they are going to get W so
essentially you are multiplying W 40
minus one times and you have these
additional you have - things like
service level to clean so now if you
look at this derivation
there are basically two sources of
vanishing radiance for the first source
of pannikin gradient which is commonly
observed by people is like this repeated
multiplication of W matrix multiply this
magnets repeatedly like we have this
issue of managing or exploiting the the
other issue which is let us notice this
this saturating activation function that
we are using in our so in general there
are these two
this is a very convenient problem and
most of you like the extra that like you
see on the top of our any opponent +
architecture I tend to solve this issue
but not the second issue so why is it
important to solve this value reading
problem it's mainly because like when we
want to learn mountain defense when I
see a lot of differences let's say like
you have some application where you have
a dependency from thousand things of
sector so in practice unless teams can
easily learn dependencies for 100 to 200
times but like after there is no
spreader
oh that is merely because of the fact
that like when you have an experience
that you have very very little feedback
to the beginning of the sequence and it
is going to take a lot and lot of time
to catch up
so some examples of long term
dependencies being that long term
predict a same hundred reinforcement
example an action that you took a week
back might have an effect so how can you
give that predator signal that if you if
you have the MS TM which is not going to
destroy anything more than ten seconds
back so this is this is one standard
application long term people Missy
really matters so the second application
would be like from the inlet so you have
a system which is learning toad it's
like time by its own task after task of
your task now when you're in such a
better setting like where you have to
remember what you the nod is to be
gained like a bunch of tasks back that
don't ask before such peptide memories
are like really amount of differences
and that is that is another application
the next immediate question is like so
we have seen that many vanilla are NL
has this issue of vanishing radiant
project so is lsdm a solution so DC your
lsdm is like the do recurrent
architecture that people use in any new
sequential tasks the first thing that
you try is another stream but is there
still a solution for long-term
difference so that's so you can see that
in the case of an esteemed I did send
updates or additive right so instead of
having a modification happens you have
an arterial
which means that you don't have the
first issue which is basically the
repeated multiplication of them right
but an STM is adding more saturating
functions in the form of gates but this
is going to create problems when it
comes to long term differences so so in
practice what happens is other streams
are better than our ones but they still
only don't owe any darkness okay
Celestials are better than the vanilla
RN that I described but in practice that
they really learn short-term differences
since the name contractor memory the
steam is not a solution so what is like
a flex are going to be a trade what is
it so you know skips has this idea of
gates like to promote information from
leaking or web to to lock the
information for longer time steps right
like so so essentially the gates need to
saturate to pass information to many now
this time but the saturation of gates
has a side effect it's actually the
variant of this the gives themselves
shrink so basically this is more like a
diatom of it being whether to saturate
or not let Zoey you want the gates to
saturate so that the information lasts
longer on the other hand electively
desaturates then the learning becomes
harder the first that you get very less
gradient so so this is a standard issue
which is less observed in other streams
simply because of the kind of tasks that
we are currently interested in most of
the standard NLP tasks and simple
reinforcement that we are considering
like so we don't have dependencies more
than hundred or 200 times that is like
you know to introduce a new market which
the volume is not saturating reference
units which will attempt to solve both
these issues in your network okay so
this is the B equation for a non
saturating your crab unit so so the idea
is very simple so there is this part
this looks like a Minotaur
so now I have conditioning WC thing's
empty minus 1 where m is basically a
flat very matter which is similar to the
said state that you have Ness G so it's
similar to sin state but except for the
fact that the allow this memory to be of
much larger studies done that even
stayed with them so that it can hold
more information if United State this I
hundred like the nominees would be of
size 500 at this also that's so that's
that's one final difference but other
than that look it's very similar to the
size okay so now the next question is
like how do we update this memory thank
you so so we update them probably using
an update rule which looks something
like this so so so what we are
essentially doing is we have these
alphas and betas which are basically
scalar values representing what to write
and what to remove so this is like the
scale content that I am writing these
are basically functions of X th gr the
previous number so yeah I'll find it
with that here are basically linear
functions all of my optional relu
non-linearity so we don't have a sigma
advantage here and similarly these reais
are normalized vectors representing
rhabdo right I'm going to write so again
they are function similar to this except
for the fact that you have an explicit
normalization after you compute these
functions so you take a summation over K
one but then use some things there oh is
it
k1 supposed to be working so I go to D 1
is equal to K 1 similarly C put one
together and like how many values does
k1 so essentially one way of looking at
this this to take your current
appearance state and come up with no
dimension of prediction of the city of
state let's call it will be K more
dimensions 100 I mentioned again state
you come up with a 10 dimensional
projection of the signal state that even
is when you're going to right every time
this low dimensional projection in
different places directions so those
directions are designed by defined by
these pas so every VA tells you which
direction to write the first unit of
this the second position and so on so
similarly you you have beta which is
basically a two-dimensional vector right
like so so which decides what we
arranged or whatever move and you are
doing that like unit way on it so that's
slick I need a of equations thank you
okay hello
how was this solving the two problems
that we have discussed before right so
the first thing is let's so the memory
updates or at it you cannot
multiplicative which means that the
first issue with our hands is taken care
of right so remember that a given and
additives additive obviously gradients
are still going to vanish but they have
much less of that of these okay and the
second thing is like we have little
gates for both the adding operation I
the removal operation like so which
means that we don't have any saturating
gauge then the only kind of gates that
we have it on saturating it slow
essentially right so this upgrade
equation should call both the vanishing
getting due to repeated matrix
multiplication and one shouldn't give
you touch rating is yes why do you have
the key to summation Y you have
information okay well I just one yes yes
so this is bit redundant
come to that but in the sense you won't
have a little non-linearity then any can
learn to act there's no there's no
motion of going but if I have little
non-linearity for all these four terms
this is the essentially strict addition
straight through the answers because all
for something this can be yes yes so we
have both adoptions like so this is just
a little description of yep
and do you know why you're not doing any
oh yes that is true so we don't do such
clipping and we do play some like
exploring it feels come to that okay so
but but to give you a very short I said
like so like I think that it's better to
be in the expert inclusion and like try
to control it and being and actually
increasing simply because there is much
there is more popular during these
different games explore if you can
control it properly then you have okay
so okay so what is she but we have to
make this a more practical architecture
is the fact that they are directly
conditioned on this huge empty vector
right so as I said before instead of
empty being 100 like it could be 500
when the USA is essentially depending on
the task you can increase the value of
this empty credit so so then you have
such a high dimensional vector your
conditional based on that WC is going to
have lots and lots of parameters which
means that this architecture can quickly
over fit if your task is based important
right let's so so that one trick that we
do to avoid this is this idea of this
idea of outer product trick so what do
you do here so basically this is the
function I am interested in producing so
let's say this young diamond sorry okay
instead of producing this M dimensional
vector I will generate two root M
dimensional vectors and do an outer
product and vector is that does it this
gives me an M dimensional output but the
two root and parameters in stuck in
square parameter so this outer product
liquid-like reduces the number of
parameters significantly by experiments
it doesn't hurt the core powers actually
we don't see we see this really slightly
better than this but no strong
comparisons
okay so before like demonstrating like
how good is this architecture like so I
would also like to briefly touch upon
the other solutions in the literature so
the first solution that I have already
mentioned this error stream which has
this issue of saturating gates then we
also have the various initialization
techniques to initialize the perfect
gate of the SDM so that this forgetting
or like forgetting of the previous
information doesn't happen often right
as though the standardization the people
use this initially in the cockpit create
by a bias to one writing like so which
comes in like picking up these different
MCS right length the most recently
introduced initially she'll text is this
idea of pro initialization which is
basically the idea that like you first
considered first first you find that
which is the maximum length of
dependency that you want then you
uniformly sample from the log of 0 to T
or 0 to routine so the basic length so
there is an initial education met this
is an efficient method for your bucket
gate based on like look whatever length
you have derived this application in
such a way that like if you use the
power of the index so you will not
forget preserving 99 percentage of what
information was that three times is back
this is a very strong operator and one
issue with both these mutualization
technique is the fact they just
institutionally so they are constraining
basically they're not constraining your
architecture to behave in such pain
these are initiation to the biases the
network can choose to under these
installation so that's the issue let me
have gr you references which has lesser
gates then STM's till they are
saturating case then very recently like
new logical Janet which is basically a
forgiving digression of LSD so the fact
that GRU is on par with the ostium are
slightly better and Janet is much better
than these two architectures itself
gives us some empirical evidence that
removing the non saturating gives gives
us some benefit so so these are the
existing solutions and there are also
some other solutions like for example so
from the non saturating aspect
we have low elements which we know are
very difficult to train because of the
experience right and people are proposed
to identities of these governments but I
think these are this initialization
techniques and painting such
architectures are very difficult in the
sense like they have a lot of
optimization so unstable frame and
there's also this temperate line of work
on advertising like this is the
orthogonal on imagery so so these kind
of architectures explicitly preserve the
gradient norm but the main issue with
these architectures is that they have no
power gating in tricky these
architectures cannot forget ever make if
you want these architectures to forget
information then you should add some
saturating gauge which ain't which
basically asks this forget gets to like
Auto parameterization of unitary
parameterization governance so that like
there's some forgetting iteration so so
will you compare with all these
solutions in the brain over so many have
strict rule given when the erasing X or
negative it's not explicitly forgetting
but like it is it is learning to remove
something of how you can figure this
across the time just close all forget
gates and they did not forget that
asleep here's to me that I would get
something pretty similar so no because
like so
when you have strict positive reading
there's anybody has two positive values
for piracy like I'll show you the value
has pocket for example it what
experiment is like when you don't reset
nobody operating be of this would the
network actually
yes yes yeah so so there are there is
new statistical unit which is basically
which claims to be an or gate as a
current unit it's martini saturating any
fashion ingredients right so but it uses
exponential moving averages for summary
statistic which means in the pages I
mean this is a compact calculator to our
model and because all the all this
monistic extensively and finally we also
have discrete addressing based networks
where the goal is explicitly to learn
more long-term difference is quite
making addressing discrete right let's
go that like you can pass variance for a
long time but but here let me use
reinforce our numbers of mass which are
either difficult to train or to scale so
in that sense so what we are proposing
currently is much simpler than this and
finally we have data for normalization
leonor a current batch knob clicks door
which helps in some tasks but not a
universal solution so yeah so these are
made differently we also compared to
intense first weeks si
okay that's you have a bigger memory and
other product cheek
we don't compare with Tosh wastes yep
then you can also make it
okay so okay so these are basically so
this is basically the number of tasks in
which the models actually talk one
performance or talk to performance for
maximum of seven tasks that we consider
and Peter compare energy with like nine
other different state of the art acting
so one thing that is different from this
summary table is that in on you is the
only model that which is in top one or
talked to across all the cosmetic one of
our goal was to show the generality of
achieving state of the art tasks by
themselves and so another thing that
people notice is like so if these
architectures like which come and talk
about one of the tasks they come in top
six are top song another task there's a
huge variance in the performance tasks
okay this table was like let's get into
the first and how do you convince a
scientifically that this pizza I'm
coming to that he says to sell the paper
but no I'm saying that because that
usually will deliver say that you will
not stay down
consider for example this happened but
someone did this to Mitch it got
rejected it appears something was well
you are scared of that you're not
reaching in all this
so quite minute when he considers seven
tasks and ten architectures no one can
achieve a love like in someone has been
competing interacted unless you have you
get like completely hundreds
conciliation perfect model XO latter
something like this we are solving the
task amounting to RP but just solve the
task there ties okay so the pasta is up
in memory task which is basically the
classical long-term dependency which was
introduced so basically you have M
different symbols and in the first K
time steps the network sees an initial
sequence of K randomly sampled symbols
from these n different symbols okay
three plays so then the resident
receives a blank symbol for a long
period of time a hundred steps under
steps you vary this difficulty is going
to be so once this is once this hundred
time steps is done and you show a t-coil
marker and the network should learn to
predict the initial sequence after the
market this is this is a synthetic task
but this is like through the point
asking essentially the only way in which
the model can solve this task is by
knowing the difference between the last
time so basically this is very explicit
dependency that and the only way mission
Allah can learn to do this task is
Madonna kiss differencing so the
commodities all of this task then you
can say that for example the time which
is hundred textures and a water source
this clasp then you can say that that
model can model
long-term differences of then this is
such a to the point is and we have tried
this with different impacts like we have
even find with the peptide 100
400 and 200 times just what we have this
is what I wonder who those are but we
don't have to search for all the
architectures only the tops you can
actually see that okay this is too much
too deep so what I would like to
highlight is this nru and this one is
the top performer this URL which is
basically an architecture hand
engineered for this tasks also this task
which is basically having a fixed time
that or 200 times does requires proper
mechanisms like you store the first few
things and to the power that so once you
reach that point so he already asked
this explicit proper mechanism and it
can actually solve this task you make
100 time steps or 200 times so this is
an architecture which is explicitly
playing it for this pass on the other
hand these are much more general that's
the next when you vary the deep in a
technique you will see the URL is okay
so how's the second one is did I you and
the next first is Janet all good buying
less control but most of the experiment
that I will show Janet an NST improve
are the competitors fix so they do
better in children
so for all the experiment that I will
show I okay especially with our nerds
that different ways to come by rocket so
one way is to make sure that they have
enough same number of parameters the
second way is to make sure the same
number of hidden States and the third
way is to make sure they have same
number of hidden units doesn't means we
go with the first approach basically
make sure that all of all that witches
have the same parameters there is no
clear winner among these three solutions
that's occasionally very expensive to do
all these three
okay okay mr. nobody was forestation
this is basically the visualization of
change in the memory so you can see the
deanship okay so this is the memory
tense x-axis is the memory stirs y-axis
is the time step so you can see that in
the initial first n time steps the
nobody is updated and once the ten-time
cells are done the memory update is
taught right and only when the model
sees recalled symbol like it starts
updating the memory so I'm going to NPM
why I don't need to Batum everyone's
rating here I hafta Whitley memory
because there is no location based
addressing remember what I have
generated I have a victim so the learns
this kind of key okay so now this second
one is like your trustee Musil basically
what happens when you have varying time
max time next here we can see that NR a
was not affected much so this is
basically so this is 0.9 is basically
the performance of a random baseline
which basically cannot use the best
followed by Janet mean good so still
Janet is a second risk but but still and
energy converges much faster than other
I mean we have the same experiment for
different time that's okay
another outsider question here how have
you control for the you know the high
profounder
leaking in stuff like how do you know
that these differences are real
difference versus you not i'll show you
seven defenders for the training methods
okay so that's that's okay that's that's
a good question and nice to see this
question to worry about like if you're
just doing one task so one thing which i
agreeing on these results is because
they we have done our task
variation in different tasks that's
different time axis different tasks than
they have been almost 15 packs so
basically like so so one thing
observation here is like without doing
much hyper parameter to me
let me get good resisted all the tasks
it which is which is a good indicator
that leg so this one is top this diaper
bag but yes if you do have a my problem
I might change but you're spending the
same budget for a better search for a
yes in fact I spend less budget for
another finally did not need any
hypothermia oh okay the only thing that
we wanted to match the number of
parameters most of the architecture is
like let it be easy so we see those huge
feet let's you would spy it's mostly for
I'm Shoni some batch tasks tasks fast
training you don't see such space there
so these pipes come up because of the
exploding idiot issue that energy would
face because there's no mention during
effect now so so we have we need better
ways of controlling air okay so this is
basically the convergence plot for all
the top three models they in are you
Jack at an escape for different they
have so you can see that so this will be
the number of steps that the network
takes to approximately you see that
approximately solve the energy is moving
much faster than Janet because this is
online during this those two simple yes
yeah okay so then like so so this is
about
there are not indifference epoch so then
there's also this classical benchmark
for forgetting ability which is the idea
of the energy so we see that this is
very similar to public on the attack
however the rate of arts are randomly
located in the noisy sequence now you
have to learn to filter this noisy
sequence and just remember that actual
data points and today
so the business would the memorization
and committing ability of artists so to
here under search so so one thing that
we observed for this task especially is
all of the forest like almost take 125
get one with the house will be solid
except for you are unlike which cannot
spot this task right pixel so basically
look more or less like all these gated
architectures would solve this task
simply because they have kids and they
can run different reviews so then it's
slightly more realistic task this is
character language morning PDB so the
numbers here might look that because if
we did not do drop out we did not we did
not do any standard little people to for
a morning which is harder to compile the
performance of active so in that sense
like so GRE was the winner of the and
are you both in terms of DC and Acuras
so they finally accept also have this
parameters equation in this password so
this is basically a I don't know I don't
have this little task for the bad ass
but it we use this for testing lot of
differences way more than long term
dependencies for me that this is more
love for testing obvious differences I
mean if any of the sequence so and Peter
this is one you are creating these
complicated dependencies in the sequence
and the task is to see if the model can
pick up these complicated this is a
batch thing you go through the examples
again and again here you see that there
is no spike in it it's teeny such issues
here and again the cure and I use the
minute all of the you are called ve
Barney
so okay this is probably the second
place where you are not is reading
simply because of the fact that you are
run has very discoverability would
people are not able to match the number
of parameters in your hand with other so
to increase the number of parameters in
you Oregon you have to make the concern
is to be also so this is Wesley only 720
across 48 pixels right so in theory he
on one can hold
all the fixes in the dream state then
this is basically the performance of the
linear or nonlinear classifier that's
sitting on the top of the heater in
state right so in that sense like you
are one has some advantage in this task
okay so summary is generally wounding
architecture to mean top la crosse auto
Samantha's that you can see again like
very similar answer yes we did
Peter some of the experiments but we did
not read an all the explosive
differences because I'm here I'm relying
on the fact that there are 10 tasks and
I'm taking the performance in 10 tasks
as the statistical conference then
having one pass with one for us okay so
he is the representative voting friends
here is back is fishing but I don't yeah
not very much okay
somebody like you know is going to
addition to be in the top to be
considered and as I asked many people
pointed alright so the only two
solutions that we found in the
literature than a flipping face value or
not but at least in the initial stages
of this project let's go so we had very
much is pretty cool
making sure that we don't have is
exploited so what is he just I don't
know even with flipping I get man
sometimes the clipping is I spent weeks
trying to come back living with are you
including Wayne on like trying to print
everything in debugging on see like when
is the thing changing so but but I still
don't
laughs already there yes but if that
happened okay so all these observations
was only in the online training tape in
full patch training I wrote I'm
seriously using a value or not in online
learning stuff like what happens is
there is just one really bad example
which takes your network far away
something actually most of the things it
comes back as you can see that there are
these huge spikes but it comes back very
quickly but sometimes like what happens
is like it just goes away I'm doing that
oh I remember this let me have this
description before so solid I tried this
trick of not doing it again the gradient
is too large but that completely these
two plates the string I don't know why
but like at least a basic training I
don't know why maybe the maybe it's not
just one step maybe it's like slowly
move towards this bad video then we try
rigor eyes standard online learning
method are you sure you're doing the
online training correctly with your
clipping yes I don't know if you're
using a demand this kind of crazy stuff
here or you're using
yes I'm acting out of yeah oh no no we
tried SGD but when we have this assuming
move SVD we have the same issues no but
I'm just saying that like if it works in
patch but it doesn't work it online it
might also be just because you don't
have the proper tracking feature for any
tool so which I still don't I spent a
couple weeks on this parameter like I do
not go back to it but this is issues so
the next thing is the paper basically
change that like when you have really
long term dependencies be do better but
when you have short term dependencies
from the experiments I see there we are
matching the performance of the other
stream a lot better than probably we
don't need to be so one of the next
Chronicle
yeah but yes you have this is ideally I
want I want a very simple architecture
but I do not need to care about what is
the difference
might ask this but as a practical maybe
as a practitioner maybe if you know that
thousand is the maximum step yes you can
use the trail and design architectures
where like you can actually use the
trail yeah but but here the board is to
have a general purpose i/o case of
having spent too much time on first part
so the second part is about training
recurrent neural networks or like this
will also be preferred with that
newest learning okay so what is my farm
running so I can learning is company one
of the dreams of explanation but the
general idea have a single agent a
single neural network learning a series
of tasks infinitely fast one thing you
might not see the same task again there
is no notion of training or testing you
perform perform and why he should be
care about that long learning so so you
should care about that for a minute
because you'll be more effective but
learning retaining knowledge across
different tasks right so which is
probably one of the ways to solve it
rather than having a single system
expert system which is to in one thing
but also it will be able to obtain
better players for the task at hand by
using the prior knowledge and exploiting
similarity across these tasks okay so
this is why what you care about that
from the center challenge is in
background there are two central
challenges which stops us from the first
challenge is the chance of catastrophic
think so so when you learn a series of
tasks when you are learning a new task
and you haven't seen the previous task
for a long time
you can forget how to perform a task in
humans but neural networks it becomes
even worse because of the gradient
design when you don't get a listen
you're seeing enough
with only one task when you're slowly
moving your network floors that pass
which means that you are essentially
unlearning like what you have that what
the previous class but this is a serious
issue and this is the central issue that
when you are they especially interested
in retaining the information from ask
and we also have this issue of capacity
saturation which is not that much
discussed in the community that so
simply because we won't have moving on
which works to even deal with this issue
like this what is this issue like so I
have a parametrized Network as fine it
let's say as the capacity to learn 10
tasks now if I'm putting this network to
test through 20 or 30 tasks then only
bringing this senator can learn the
level task so you get a static
forgetting also because of capacity
situation so there are two sources of
oneness capacity saturation another
source is the grain visit itself right
it so when you do NW for one task W
other things other but with capacity
circulation that so there of course
there are many solutions there is a
panic why not start with a much bigger
Network just yes yes yes so basic so my
point is similar in the sense that even
if you start with a very good the first
coordinate you don't know what that
perform right so that you start with a
2,000 finit network that which can hold
in task what if I give you 20 tasks so
basically you don't know how many
parameters you need in beforehand in
such a setting even if you know that as
you also find it out that even if you
know that then you might not have that
generalization simply because you have
enough capacity to remember everything
so we direct the two serious issues that
needs to be resolved so based on these
issues so we list out the bunch of
characteristics that an ideal this is
not a new list like people are trying to
come up with this this project last 20
years or 30 years
we are just trying to be more rigorous
base already and also visit the
locations for the project okay so the
first idea characteristics this like a
light normally should this one should
have knowledge retention in the sense if
it learn some new information from
previous tasks it should be able to
retain that I'm not forget that this is
just perfect
this the second decidable characteristic
is like it should be able to do
knowledge transfer
it's a knowledge transfer it means that
like whatever if you learned from the
previous tasks to be able to reuse those
information and learn the next class
much faster also other the third
important characteristics is the
parameter division I don't want the
parameters of the network to grow
linearly even linearly there are edges
which grows quadratically but i going to
want the parameters to grow even
linearly i want an architecture where
the parameters grow something nearly
just to the wrong tasks so that's the
third character the final
characteristics is the ability to model
it crunched I need an architecture I
need a general purpose architecture
which can expand its capacity as and
when needed right let's so but again
there are some concerns with model
expansion so for example we have ideas
like walls it is solution this relation
in general it's so bad you take a
network this to a larger network right
so but distillation records a lot of
height but in the true night problem
sitting I want a zero shot distillation
ology was shot expansion of the memory
so these are like before
ideal so now before showing you the
architecture that we are using this I'll
also do this briefly the other existing
solutions for both these central
challenges so the standard are a bunch
of standard solutions literally the
first solution is to freeze the parts of
the model as it thinks or successive
tasks so for example elastic wait
consolidation does that so essentially
the ribbon is the parameter updates in
such a way the parameters which are
useful for the previous tasks are
updated in less when compared to
parameters which are not that useful for
various tasks okay so
so you're basically the second example
which is on the update so we have this
kind of modest distillation idea right
let's go
this dude from a smaller network to a
larger network I can imagine it with a
smaller but as I mentioned before this
relation is not that good in the setting
simply because it requires all the
examples it has to go through a period
of distillation this is for capacity is
much say you want to expand the model so
the solution to come up with these
function preserving transformations we
expand a small train network to a large
country network this is the idea of net
net you basically take a train network
and do it zero SWAT expansion of network
not training in the case there is no
delay in expansion but there are other
solutions that
network per task this video post edition
examples are processing networks and
network all right so basically these
these papers will show results with two
or three tasks but if you want to do 100
tasks then you need 100 it works as this
counter it works for the whole thing
like this one network per task is not
this relation so these are like
different ways of solving model
expansion okay so this table I have
talked about some of the other solutions
but you can read that in the paper but
this table basically character it takes
all these data models and can't
producers like so like like which of the
desirable characteristic that they
satisfy so but now we are looking for
one model which will satisfy all these
for slowly so as you can see you want on
an expansion for sure which means that
either only three what is possible out
of its these two are for escalation so
we just choose definition so Annette
Annette hand model expansion
capabilities now the next question is
with what model can become Queen hitting
it with so that you get all the four
characters there are two options Jim or
mm in my opinion both are not
satisfactory relations but German is
like evaluated be much more tasks than
my mmm incremental moment mashing and
also don't be like scalable solution not
scalable in terms of computation because
like you know through these examples
again and again but but scalable to
larger tasks so essentially like what we
do in this work which is more of an
expert level is to combine detonate with
fading elsewhere so both very episodic
memory and mental virtue already
proposed for a feed-forward setting and
even though the inspiration was
continuing learning they just do one
task basically ask and the training
saturates that will just expand liquid
and repeat the same class packets with
it that is not an ordinary hand sitting
in the sense that you see the same
examples even after expansion so so so
what not the contribution scalar X this
is not so interesting or exciting is to
test that these two are solutions which
were proposed only four feet over at
Rich's
work even in intensity so that the
little bit of modifications yes they
work properly in fraternal settings but
the main contribution here is to come up
with this single model which has all
these decisions characteristics and
evaluate the benefit of such models okay
so even before showing you spin what are
you must need for each one so basically
there is this absence of standardized
training and evaluation which must for
lifelong learning which is kind of
kindling the prophecy life so even
though people are talking about that one
going away 30 or 40 years it's going to
be are they able to come up with
temporal systems like what I propose
here simply because of the progress in
we have put enough single pass systems
that we started weighing like we are now
starting to worry about these kind of
particular incident so even then we
don't have shattered in tchaikovsky
which means that people count with a
voltage cross which are Piyush yes
because how do i benchmark but that's
the problem so some people come up with
five benchmarks and everyone has the
voltage part then it becomes difficult
to come up with others right there is no
standard benchmark for testing set
architectures and also there is no
standard benchmark which explicitly
acts one of these powers they're
actually fairly at the station for
example producing if there is no paper
which talks about capacitive function in
like Lauren's wedding so even though
that's the inspiration for many of the
standard solutions in the literature
okay
but for supervised learning we have
these simple tasks like 450mm lists
based data set or some hundred base data
support or like from learning and they
are like very simple innocence you take
the MS dataset consider two three random
classes some [ __ ] today tested then
three other is considered as and PDFs
like these are simple for you I simple
take assess and for reinforcement
learning there is no standards which
works and also people mostly use very
few games they most of the particularly
papers in reinforcement direct lose at
max it gives not more than that so so
with file games like we really get about
it
are you going to saturate capacity I'm
not sure let's so basically the other
need is it does move in the sequence
which is what we are pitching at and I
will explain why you should do
sequential problems in that long run so
one reason is sequential supervised
learning is more close to the are
setting so I amended reinforcement
learning setting but struggle when we
are like sitting we can take it in
either pain so this is this is move this
is literally much better than like
having Emily starts the 100 just what I
am reading and the the main advantage
then we move to sequential setting for
non sequential by just increasing the
sequence length so this actually helps
us to study this problem of capacity
expansion even the coffee table any
sequential
basic attack instead of considering
people one-step solutions like we are
looking at my pistol solution so that so
that yes yes so one of the thing that
the paper is pitching is to consider
right from running with setup simply
because they you have these additional
nice things that you don't see in our
city where is the change see between
sequences okay
also it is easy to define a series of
tasks where is Percy porcelain a
speculum so so basically like I can keep
on increasing the difficulty by just
increasing that correct like increasing
the seeker but when they initially come
up with this like so that at least let's
travel was not satisfactory in it he
thought it is really simple curriculum
but surprisingly so we have this result
for the chemist iam now creating a
custom on a sequence should ask which is
here a sequential stroke M this I'll
explain what the task in that doesn't
matter what part is here here is the
sequential task button training an LST M
sequence length as the curriculum yep
and goodbye to your previous to varying
the interval length when you need them
memorize also be an example yes yes yes
you say yes so yeah so that would be one
of the stay so but but in this case so
the interesting observation here
like I'm just training or any this works
for any secret I'm training on a secret
Espace I'm training with sequence length
so the tasks here is be the length of
the sequence it could be one two three
four five multiples of P let's say it's
some multiples of the sequence length
okay so now you can see that I trained
with just sequence with one let's take a
warning okay there - I test it with
other sequence list obviously the
performance will be bad
okay now I claim the network just
sequence length - so please say that we
basically clear the number - I never
liked the performance is more than 90%
so when it receives more than 90% age
you look at the backward transfer for
equals let what it has not only sequence
with one all of the sequence length -
now it is war between two sequence
length - in the same state if the
performance for sequence won't drop
significantly
oh let's not worry about the forward
transfer because power is always going
to back but Isis as you see here Lacaze
I suggest training base for sequence
length as the curriculum that itself is
challenging for them simply because that
sequence which is still not I'll go to
the week
productions kind of convincing
curriculum to use okay so now we also
proposed a bunch of simple tasks you
have control over the tasks and also as
task is copying tasks and be called a
long sequence of a defector
so basically given sequence of random
vectors followed by a plan I want to
[Music]
start with then three six nine twelve
basically like okay so we'll fire the
training with length 3 and the ricotta
cheese 90% accuracy removal in six you
touching my nipple piercing you move to
learn I am writing it so whenever it's
there is to clear the accuracy within
let's say 20,000 times that we stop the
training basically the network has
failed
the second task is a supposed to be
faithful
it's kind of an algorithmic task where
after showing a sequence of items the
network
I'm going to show them to the random
item has to say what was the next item
after this I know I'll share items are
usually another sequence of random
vectors basically random vector block
has it that the random vector
are you sure all of them that is a task
here I mean the numbers are length of
the sequence the matrix equation so we
have an even more challenging task is
what we call as the benchmark which is
so basically kill each analyst image is
going to be represented as a sequence of
strokes so instead of pixels like to see
sequel pixel it's realistic so it's
gonna be sequence of strokes it might
look like a simpler problem but we make
the problem much more challenging by
giving T equals of pen strokes sequences
basically like I take ten digits I have
the strictest stroke information for all
the integers feed them but in energy to
system our output is the corresponding
sequence of digits in the same order so
this is a much more challenging task
then the previous to pass on also much
more realistic because this involves I'm
learning it is not just copying right it
was some learning and then it has to
learn to chunk the sequence first then
it should be learn to recognize the
sequence is the chunk they don't should
learn to remember the digits in this
game order like this this involves much
more from if you expect much more from
the left and the thing is yeah I mean
the timers are number of widgets which
attack you okay so this as I said is
like so we are going to consider each
task as a domain and each difficulty
level as a task that's it is
specification are going to do online
training no separate validation test set
and whenever the time task activity is
greater than index a 90% H when the
level is clear the network is you can
move the next level right now however
the network still sees all the examples
in one day before complete to make sure
that different networks have the same
number of days just to make just to be
fine with all the architectures that we
show the same examples even though the
gear drive and if it report the current
task accuracy which is basically how
good is the network in this task devious
classic you'll see which is a summary of
all the backward transfer
and future tasks activity which is the
summary of all the future times so one
nice thing about the sequential title of
this training is if the same task but
the different difficult deliver it so I
can actually compute the forward
transfer unlike like sitting while you
have different tasks that's a hack but
yes it's useful for us okay if whatever
is not clear to the training stock
however when you consider models with
expressions we will know the network
will train after one step of expansion
the model please expand I said able to
combine very difficult in company with
nature so what is very moving and then
training on a level the parameter
gradient is projected to make sure that
the gradient update does not decrease
the loss on the previous tasks so you
basically okay the one downside is it
reduces the back of the model as is the
case with any cup any catastrophe of the
installations another issue I believe is
for training examples from the previous
aspect let's go the in practice what we
do is if we randomly pick like ten
examples and just use those ten examples
as a recursive data for the previous
task and surprisingly that works very
well
okay the second solution is net which is
zero for knowledge transfer a small
trained teacher to a large entrance to
it by using puncture preserve in
transfer this is a very really neat
technique in the sense so what is
essentially do is the cake is trained
teacher network okay I'm trained by an
expat is pounded into theta so how do we
do that
the basically this abandoned way of
mapping from the teacher
let's say you have 100 units and you
want to expand it 250 units whatever to
do this it was good coffee okay
then you are going to randomly replicate
50 of these hundred units so that's it
so now to make sure that the output the
same you have to divide by do for these
units so I'm not going to explain the
math but that's what they are doing so
basically you divided output by 2 for
such that those
the hope is illusory boom but yes you
are going to have that solution right
but our claim is like this is going to
remember more than any of the other
active okay some results this is the
current task accuracy in competencies
has nothing to do with the backward a
few times right it just shows like how
good is it following that path that has
okay for a for a upper bound we have
this real in larger industrial and this
blu-ray is actually our current in a
stream which is much smaller and you can
see that the smaller relased you take
yourself is point a so then we expand
the other stream then it actually feels
more diverse
on the other hand when you do a larger
interest you with gem of days remember
that this main line even though it looks
good it's not useful because it just
don't have any bad backward transfer to
be more network just doing good in a
time task
plus our good photographs like so so
this is such model and you are beating
that model when adding model expansion
capabilities but this so misty this is a
smaller network with develop dates and
capacity expansion which clears more
level than a larger network with just
generates general things this also
highlights the fact that when you add
gym the capacity decreases you can see
it from 14 levels it becomes 10 levels
because of the capacity exhaustion they
have first division Thames with same is
observed for
the different a specifically called or
secretiveness so then let's look at the
backward turn backward transfer this is
a good this is the achieve this is a
largely reduced iam with Jim objects
right this is this is the upper bound
and here you have two things the smaller
in the stream we just need to let this
moves fashion and there's a smaller list
you first came motion this is smaller in
the stream retina cluster this is our
model and I can see that this is doing
better than the function is obvious and
it's also doing much like see the
similar this is for all the three tasks
finally the power transfer so here
there's no modulus team good check
so you can see the right but I mean like
here if you don't know which is the
power transfer we don't know which is
the okay
somebody so here your argument that the
Green Line is not the best use of the
forward and one of the three centers you
have a different good standards like for
example the large intestine is good for
the class and for the future does but
not for the previous term so the same
model know the large step is doing the
best in all the trick is because the
larger the scheme is the that was the
serious issue with our pass the change
happens in everything but here is the
obvious here this is marjoram question
which is the
[Applause]
oh yes and what we don't input here is
going to be how also does expand it
multiple times basically like an X file
as many time as you want
it is a dangerous path oh one thing that
we spend so much time is that looks like
very simple solution and it looks like
it is not the solution which it's been
so much better
so that's actually a good
maybe never but Tommy like it looks like
the better okay so net tonight gem what
has been a place for conditioning your
sequential tasks is the early task
sequence for some tasks yeah you know
for most years yes but it's a basically
only a task for which are sequences a
lot like in the first part you already
had a copy task but I say this is a
different
so that is Palatinate that bison record
morning this is let's just like hockey
league sequence of numbers if this is
copying sequence of random characters it
contains vectors
no that's defined any vectors but that's
just one heart this is this is not
harder for you women we have more
teacher number yeah they can use the n
ru oh we can use an ax so these two are
the parallel projects yeah yeah so yeah
one thing that we definitely want to see
is like as all these observations on the
other stream pools for I got very good
impression but I would expect similar
results because they kill the boar is
not peace has come out that long time
the currency cast probably doing how
same as last year
yeah another interesting thing which is
also ok another boring thing to try it
is like so to actually like test the
same come up with let's see if we can
come up with similar conclusion for all
the static electricity understand are
you GRU
so all you see is that this something
useful to know but it's also very going
to as computationally expensive well Jim
update takes a lot of things
another interesting research pushing
here is like so can we come up with
better ways of catastrophic both elastic
week consolidation engine that's another
miss play you can improve definite 5 and
H now is the what we claim as an
advantage without a press thing now if
you improve these doses that's a
registration of the way that you set
this up is that you have oh you're silly
you have control over asking for the
next ask right because you decide that
there's a variable then we say it gave
me that harder problem a lot of the time
in real world you can't ask yes/no I
just come at here
yeah that might be another
generalization yes that is true so that
is a different aspect of
if I can explicitly
[Music]
sometimes we this one oh yeah
so another thing that we tried is like
to something like partying club strip so
basically when you fix high performance
actuators like this probably it's better
to expand here than here because it when
you are menu on the saturated zone that
you have already unlearned something
like this old so one thing that we
experimented with is to have companies
like keep length a few snapshots of the
model and choose to expand like when we
face here I think so when you say the
previous the previous husk
you mean the average so this is an
average of all the biggest
[Applause]